[Music]
as one of the largest home improvement
retailers our strategy really revolves
around winning the customer and better
competing for the pro by enabling both
customer segments to make homes better
for all from inspiration to installation
we want our customers to have the best
experience with us
regardless of how when or where they
choose to shop
for our devops
look our philosophy is really an
approach to software development that
enables
teams to build test and release software
faster and more reliably did we uncover
anything surprising yes
so our 300x increase in release velocity
and gcp's ability to support the scaling
was an added value the power and
potential of gcp and
our google sre principles enable us to
achieve a lot of this automation very
seamlessly and we were able to focus on
reliability and technology an example of
this includes collaborating and
strategizing the change request
automation process with i.t service
management and optimizing our regression
and performance test suites and at the
core of our devops ecosystem we have
four principles we follow
ownership and accountability what that
really means is our teams are fully
committed from birth of an idea to the
products launch
systems thinking
performance of the entire technology
ecosystem takes precedence over the
performance of a specific team
continuous experimentation and learning
and automation it's an awesome
experience you know all that partnership
the weekly calls that we have with the
google team so with our devops
transformation to google cloud we've
gone from doing
30 releases to more than
4 500 releases per year look what this
means is going from one release every
two weeks to more than 20 releases daily
a massive improvement i'm so excited to
win this award
and it showcases our team's journey
right how we continue to power our
devops and sre principles this award is
a recognition for both google and lowe's